katia bonjour alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
retenir après ces annonces du secrétaire
général de l'elysée on a les noms des
nouveaux ministres du gouvernement coûté
finalement peu de surprises même si
elles sont de taille
je vais d'abord rappelé les ministres
qui reste en poste inquiets ont été
confirmés dont bruno le maire à bercy
florence parly ministre des armées
monsieur blanc caire à l'éducation
olivier ferrand est la santé jean yves
le drian aux affaires étrangères comme
prévu il y a évidemment un jeu de
chaises musicales entre ministères qu'à
une partie des ministres restent au sein
des ministères même si ils n'ont pas ce
qu'ils avaient précédemment alors donc
de normandie à l'agriculture elisabeth
bornes
un ministre du travail et de l'emploi
sébastien lecornu aux outre mer et puis
jacqueline au gourou aux collectivités
voilà pour des ministres des personnes
qui faisait déjà partie du gouvernement
et puis il y à une entrée donc celle de
barbara pompidou transfuge de lv devenu
la république en marche elle elle prend
donc ses nouvelles fonctions est ce que
c'est un choix audacieux en tout cas ce
n'est pas véritablement une surprise en
son nom circulait déjà alors les
surprises parlons-en
gérald darmanin qui va occuper le poste
de ministre de l'intérieur c'est vrai
que c'est un poste clé un poste qui
était convoité on savait très bien que
christophe castaner était en partance
car il était extrêmement contestée par
les syndicats policiers
or voilà gérard dalmat darmanin s le
choix des manuels maquereau ou du
nouveau premier ministre jean castex
on ne sait pas puisque on avait parlé de
blanc caire à ce poste mais en réalité
c'est désormais gérald darmanin 2
devait organiser de reprendre les rênes
de ce ministère maintenant venons en aux
surprises roselyne bachelot à la culture
il est vrai qu'elle avait fait un retour
médiatique assez retentissant
grâce à sa gestion à l'époque elle était
ministre de de la grippe h1n1 elle avait
extrêmement bien réagi en tant que
ministre donc elle a eu un retour de
flamme de l'opinion elle avait été
décriée à l'époque mais elle a fait une
une audition à s'est enflammé il ya
quelques jours donc peut-être est-ce que
celui cela lui a donné des points pour
occuper ce nouveau ministère et puis
évidemment
l'avocat pénaliste dupond-moretti
devient garde des sceaux alors là
réellement je pense que tout le monde
autour de moi mes confrères et bien sont
aussi surpris que moi en effet dû donc
certains avocats extrêmement médiatique
surnommé aquitator un surnom qu'il
n'aime pas mais qui marque son
excellence en tant qu'avocat il y en a
sont 146 145e acquittement en février
2020 il a eu pour client patrick balkany
abdelkader meira bernard tapie donc un
expert un homme de loi extrêmement
compétent qui rejoint les rangs de la
république en marche on note également
la nomination de gabriella talent en
tant que porte parole et donc la
disparition de six bêtes ya ndiaye qui
n'est pas dans les listes qui n'apparaît
pas dans les listes
et puis marianne schiappa qui va occuper
un poste de ministre délégué à la
citoyenneté au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur voici pour un certain nombre
de noms et sachant qu'il y a
existe un grand nombre de ministres
délégués beaucoup plus important que
celui de l'ancien gouvernement
merci beaucoup catia pour toutes ces
précisions on vous retrouve bien
évidemment tout au long de cette soirée
katia technique en direct aux abords du
palais de l'elysée